all right welcome to a new video i'll be
doing a war zone video again it's a
tournament starting in 1 minute 20
seconds i'm starting the video early so
this is because i want to post also a
reminder for the charity event that a
player here on chef cube is doing and
this is starting in a few hours it's i
think six some PM eastern standard time
US East Coast time which would be a yeah
midnight in in Central Europe on
midnight from the 17th to the 18th and
it's a it's a charity event he will be
playing 1000 consecutive bullet games I
hope he's got all his friends there too
well to cook for him and take care of
him while he's playing this thousand
games this is quite a lot I checked that
I also played thousand games on chess
cube button I didn't know three or four
weeks and he will be doing this yes
straighten in one hour it's a charity
went to raise money for breast cancer
research and post the details also in
the description so make sure if you play
on chest cube to to check it here it's a
goose 02 02 is seas cafe here um yeah
all join in or play against him yeah
another tournament starting and it's um
it's a book war zone tab tournament
two-minute games and often play for here
to to get in quicker wins but often I
also tricked myself because I don't know
don't know the theory is so well
for instance I have no idea how how this
kind of position is played
yeah maybe you can just I can take on e6
if it takes on you for now i can i can
sacrifice only six but other than that I
don't have a clue here okay f5 is a good
square maybe still can take on you for
this looks dubious I don't have I can
take on here threaten on g7 if he takes
on h6 Queen h6 ng7 s is a maid I also
threaten queen take 36 as the bishops on
b3 pinning the night to the pawn right
okay let's let's keep it simple here
yeah now i can i can win the Queen after
the night is moved
yeah just an extra Queen all right seven
was hanging but of course a queen is the
queen it doesn't resign though
unfortunately yep yeah the thing is you
these tournaments always last yeah
usually the last 30 minutes there are
also some which lasts 45 minutes or one
hour but usually 30 minutes and you need
to get in the winds quickly so it's a
good idea to to place some what yeah
sharp a staff to to win the games in a
quick fashion and it's also very helpful
if the opponent's actually resigned
quickly and simply get in more points
okay this is maybe not completely
serious but f2 and h2 and queen edge for
this might be a good way to to score a
quick win web 7 is hanging wow I should
have played here a 95 first this was
lucky but this is not very good for me
because I can I cannot take here
there is no maid and I can take here
also okay let's retreat here and try to
try to get in buena Bishop to g4 I could
play an IDF form ending to be careful I
was trying to win quickly and it often
works but sometimes while trying to win
quickly you really get yourself into
trouble like I did here I should have
taken out one of course but suppose I
was possible all the time it's just a
great position yeah now i will piss down
from not much
need to try and get some some play
against the king ya know the bishop has
no square but he's got 96 and moves like
this look every hole irritating right to
know that's specialist hanging a really
a terrible game I keep on overlooking
simple stuff here yeah now I've got what
is it a couple of extra points one extra
pond and it's got the completely ranking
position
yeah this should hopefully lead to two
quick media group g1 yeah this was very
shaky game with lots of blunders all
right yeah Kings Indian somewhat unusual
933 plans 9h form which senses piece
back here oh man I'm really playing crap
here of course I need to cover your form
yeah I don't do comentarii for those
golden tone tournaments usually because
of the time control I'm pretty good at
this time control but I really need to
concentrate sorry
yeah okay this is still it's not great
but it's maybe player got some some play
against the King here rook g6 I'll just
push it back Bishop 86 just now do a
castle yeah maybe could also think of
King move yeah my black should just play
Queen age 7 yeah
yeah 95 now coming yeah this is maybe
not the best move but I want I want a
simple position don't make some moves
quickly here
you might try to play rook c8 yeah it's
up a good colors but tubes surprisingly
didn't exchange the ropes I'm a bit
ahead on time which is assuring right
okay its opposite colored bishops but Q
connected passed pawns is usually too
much it can be a draw sometimes but yeah
this is my next move yeah I'm in the
lead somewhat shaky play nevertheless
yeah I've got three out of three and
second one also but somehow it didn't
press this doubling cube so I guess all
the time therefore it's got less points
you always need to to to to double here
oh no move
yes sometimes sometimes players are just
just not moving instead of just refusing
the doubling cube are pausing the
tournament beforehand they decide to let
the two minutes run out and yeah
sometimes the tournament seems very very
close I even resigned and so in such
situations to get a game quicker it's
very debatable if this is a good
strategy but ok for the time I would
just wait this out I hope this is the
case it's not a disconnect bye Mia yeah
yeah while while while we're waiting I
can get back to the charity when ya go
sir 02 02 is this a cafe and is playing
all this games for charity and yeah it's
a good idea maybe show up and play
against him more on learn more about
them the the organization he raises some
money for and to think it so it's a good
good thing to do um and also if you
don't play on shares cube already it's
also worth joining it so completely for
free and you can play all these fun
tournaments yeah while I'm waiting here
for this guy to let his clock ran out
someone has overtaken me here
now with the points here I am I think I
should be in the lead again it's so
completely annoying as it also destroys
your you're playing rhythm at least for
me yeah usually I play you forward
sometimes my old habits kick in and I
play d4 by accident okay it's not not a
big deal of course ideas queen to h3 and
then get something going against h7 this
kind of position is already a rather
problematic for black white just gets
gets a great attack yeah this gives
gives up on for nothing I think okay
keep it simple maybe the other capture
was a more exact maybe ok
yeah just an extra Brooke
yeah this is made next move I think
Queen g7 of7 cannot okay could I play
Queen g2 or something yeah I'm second
place yeah the other guy here tries to
get the quick attack on the edge file I
sector porn here to quickly get my
pieces going I'm quite good compensation
here it's not very well coordinated
yeah shut up Peter the palm back ok
cannot play King to g2 let's see how we
cover this up now this is a very
annoying pin not quite sure what is
movers to avoid material losses i think
there is none now go for the next pin
again so he needs to exchange them more
try to get quickly on f2 and now if 2 is
just falling ok can i play ok f'kin i
can just capture it maybe i can somehow
play against this night just take it
threatening g2g to g1 the night is
completely dominated yeah it's good good
to try to play for me if you've got the
chance because it is simply quicker than
win the long end game I should play you
for keep on forgetting this it's also a
matter of time now you have got the huge
time penalty against almost everyone and
now no this guy is also running the
clock down this is unbelievable yeah
what can you do we need to wait two
minutes should I just no no no it's
responding ok maybe it was just
distracted by something yeah already
nice position here one a couple of Tempe
the [ __ ] should win a material somehow
Barbie five maybe be five you have this
gets gets ugly not
winning the Queen
yeah it's difficult this tournament
people don't resign let the clock run
down and so on it's unfortunately a real
um it's really am important those issues
I could easily play two games more
without this yeah really wonder why
people do that you can just resign get a
new game and maybe win a game instead of
staring one and a half emitted on this
this position
yeah 54
yeah I got seven out of seven just as
the first guy but some why am I missing
a point here maybe the guy who let the
clock run down from one not sure I think
I pressed the double all the time now I
don't get a game
okay let's hope for for a quick win now
yeah this wasn't exactly great yeah this
happens for trying to to play
aggressively you just play here badly
not quite sure how bad it is already
maybe it is okay what cannot cannot
cancel also this is risky of course
turning Queen 85 but you might take here
can play Queen 85 I love this piece I
could take on
okay let's keep it simple no quick may
put my king position is somewhat scary
in the middle
here try to play quickly
83 to come to grab g2 and now the bishop
helps yeah this was helpful to win
quicker yeah first place but he has a
finish this game yet keep on forgetting
to play your form okay got a queen sir
gambit here very standard position yeah
try to prevent some SC 5 okay you cannot
place you five anymore looks very nice
for white
this doesn't matter like so much sense
but I could have played a five this
would have been a good idea I try to
switch now to King cytotec here
yeah Oh 92 we need to be careful I don't
mind the exchange so much because I I
still have a huge attack
so take on g6 maybe I can prepare this
hmm yeah this is really annoying this
pin okay one was a good move
okay so down on timely to gamble here
ok
Luke h1 was one wow this was completely
lucky he who could have played rook age
one mate yeah okay but this took so much
time that the other guy who took me
again yeah I'm not playing so well
really aunt a bit unlucky with unfair
people all around but after all I need
to win quicker and I could have lost at
least one game okay try for some real
quick action here no matter if it's
correct or not oh this was helpful
resigned especially yeah okay now I'm
just one point down maybe I have a shot
I wouldn't really quickly know I should
have gone if I make a i'm not sure what
i'm doing here why I don't go for your
far as I want s'ok really crappy
position
just clearly worse here yeah and it's
easy to play as well for luck maybe I
should have grabbed f 6m yeah I'm not in
good shape here hey okay now i take it
maybe your resins now this would be
really helpful
yeah it's just 30 seconds left yeah I'm
in the lead but the other guide is most
likely still playing okay if i can win
super quickly here but 30 seconds it's
very very unlikely
ok this is complete credit
not quite sure what did i do first so
second place first place wow this was
lucky really lucky I played really badly
could have lost lost at least 42 games
or something but okay very lucky somehow
he didn't manage to finish this game I'm
not sure what he did there and it's not
a loss or something he just didn't
finish or maybe some technical technical
issue not sure yeah well okay the main
point was not the tournament anyway but
to remind you of the great charity event
today so check out goose cafe in about
now as it's 15 minutes past 2 p.m. here
in Germany and this would be a min for
in 10 hours so check it out 6 6 p.m.
eastern standard time today yeah until
then maybe we'll see each other on
playing goose I would do so i guess um
maybe tonight or tomorrow i think it
will last I don't know 20 hours so
longer so it's quite some time you have
to check out playing him alright see you
till the next video